do you guys though have like at least
that one like
anime convention story that you share
with people though because like i have
like a million
yeah i mean like but that one that just
sticks out to you it's just like you
meet somebody or
i should specify that one convention
story where somebody
was the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah because i
we have one morals just go out the
window i swear
i should we should probably tell this
one when we're both on this podcast
um because i remember the one the one
guy
that ever stood out to both of us i've
told this story on sydney's channel
before
but it was the very first time me and
sydney had met
in person yeah and like probably started
dating so
anyone who's been in a long distance
relationship will
know how difficult that is like when you
don't get to see
your partner very often so you have to
like treasure every moment that you get
to
you know be we've been be with your
partner yeah now this was the very first
time we met met in person
and it was 2014 a cent and
on the last day um we had to say our
goodbyes
yeah and obviously it was a very very
a very very i know this one it was a
very very tearful goodbye because
obviously
at the time we didn't know when we would
next get to see each other right
so sydney was in my arms and she was
like crying it was like
it wasn't like a subtle cry it was a
proper crying it was like an ugly crack
it was like makeup spewed all over your
face kind of crying
like he's going to warrant yeah yeah and
like i'm like comforting her i'm just
just as
as we're just as we're just like hugging
together i just hear in the corner of my
ear
giggot and i was just like and i was
just like
no way i know she's like it's not even
the worst part yet i love this story so
much
and i just saw her just be like
hi and and there's just just
this guy standing at me and he he had
like he had like the you know the
surprise
face and you know i i was i was trying
to like
like signal like look look at sydney
look at sydney
like a sydney like like just just give
us a moment because this is my very
first convention
in america and like probably my very
first convention as like as like a
youtuber so i wasn't used to getting
recognized if i had
if this happened now i'd be like dude
can you give us a moment but back then
i did not know how to deal with it you
didn't know how to say hold on yeah i
didn't have to say no basically
so he was like can i take a picture and
i'm just like
inside i was like is this guy serious
yeah it's right this guy [ __ ] serious
right now
i'm just like i'm like um oh okay sure
and then so
like we separate right yeah we go to the
side and he goes wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
no no no i i got this i got this i got
this i got this so
so he he tries taking some pictures
right and he does he does the thing
where the first selfie he's not happy
with so he's just like no
let me try again okay okay no you get
you get three and then i'm like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and he tries the third time and he's
still not happy and then he looks over
to sydney
makeup all over her face tears down her
tears down her [ __ ] face or like all
over her cheeks
and i'm just like don't do it don't
[ __ ] do it
don't [ __ ] do it can you take a
picture
crying and i'm like sure because i
didn't know i was so
i did it
he has the goal to ask cindy to take a
picture for us
i'm like i i was just i went from like
really really sad that i'm not gonna say
sydney for a while to just like confused
angry
to be like is this guy for real is this
he's
is he for real like how how are you
feeling in that moment
i was pretty pissed i was like angry but
i was like because i thought maybe like
is this normal
yes he's like a big star i should know
so i
should know better and at least at least
he wasn't like
hey sydney do you want to be in the
photo with us oh my god
that would have been about clean
yourself up and then get in the field
put some water on come back